the planet's climate has become more and
more of an issue to many including in
the corporate world for example
investment funds are increasingly
assessing how climate-friendly a company
is
before investing in it the carbon
disclosure project cdp a nonprofit
organization has been looking at how
environmentally friendly companies are
based on their impact on forests water
systems and
the climate around 13 000 companies
submitted data to the project this year
combined they make up 64 percent of
global market capitalization the most
ever but only 2 percent
of those companies managed to get the
top level a ranking in one of the three
categories and just 14
of those 13 000 examined managed to back
the a rating for all three categories
meaning the efforts to protect water
forests and the climate
let's take a closer look at this with
dexter galvin he's global director
corporations and supply chains at cdp
welcome to the program dexter good to
have you um 13 no 14 of 13 000 companies
meeting the top criteria in climate
water and forest protection that's not a
lot is it
no it's not um and it's a fantastic
achievement for those 14 organizations
but it is uh
an indictment on the wider corporate
community that we haven't done enough in
this space um over the past couple of
decades and we are left with eight years
to save the world essentially
give us an example of what sort
environmental efforts these 14 companies
were showing
that others were not
so if we take a look at the types of
data that we're looking at
we're looking at climate change action
so their ability to report on their
carbon emissions the breadth and depth
of their carbon emissions reduction
targets
whether it's a science-based target and
whether it's actually been independently
verified
by the science-based target initiative
which means their targets are actually
in line with the science of climate
change
whether they can account for their water
consumption and whether they have data
on what's happening in their supply
chain because on all of these topics
deforestation water and climate change
the vast majority of the impact is
actually in the supply chain of a lot of
these major organizations so
these 14 organizations will be showing
that they are reducing their impact uh
in their own operations but critically
also
engaging with suppliers to reduce their
impact and reducing the impact of their
pro product portfolio
downstream as well
dexter can sustainability efforts be
allocated
to certain regions countries
or economic sectors
well there's certain um in our a-list
this year we have some clear leading
comp countries so for example
asia and europe are the regions that
have performed the best in the world
this year and japan is definitely
leading the pack in asia if we look into
europe we've got 23 french companies on
the a-list and they're the leaders in
europe followed by
the uh the british the uk
at 15 and then germany at 14.
why is it that these uh
regions these countries and the
companies stemming from there are at the
forefront
i think it's a mixture of
policy
environment these countries tend to have
um
quite advanced uh initiatives at the the
government level um some good policy
structure um clear signaling from the
government that
that this is only going one way that
that the country is going in the
direction of net zero all of those
countries have clear and net zero
targets at a national level um i also
think consumer pressure particularly in
france the uk and germany is a big
driver of corporate action on this issue
and of course
those countries have quite advanced
finance sectors and in the last couple
of years we've seen an explosion of
interest in esg as we call it
environmental social governance data
there's literally trillions of dollars
sloshing around in the esg space these
days that's really helping to drive
corporate action and those companies
that are taking action and getting into
our a-list are actually receiving a
large bulk of that cash
so they're actually being rewarded by
the markets
dexter gavin global director
corporations and supply chains at cdp
dexter thank you